handball ist luca und wenn ich es
schaffe diesen ball in diesem korb
vornherein zu werten dann findest du
noch diesen monat die liebe deines
lebens nicht mehr die letzten monate
fragen die von einem kaktus zugeht
nein ich hab mich gar keiner gefragt
aber ich würde euch einfach zeigen man
damit angeben dass der kaktus immer noch
lebt und extrem krass gewachsen ist
und ein bisschen dabei das regal dass
ihr meine videos immer im hintergrund
sieht aufzuräumen und ihr an ich was ich
in dieser schublade hier gefunden habe
es ist das allererste handy das ich je
hatte das ist einfach so nokia 63 00 die
einzige schramme die das ding hat jetzt
hier oben wenig dass der lack ab ist
aber das ist das kannst du hin speisen
wie sonst was damit passiert überhaupt
nichts
also ich meine ich kann es jetzt nicht
an machen weil ja ich meine was ist das
für ein anschluss war oder war erst wenn
die schon smartphone oder habt ihr noch
gar kein handy stimmt das hat mich nicht
interessiert
gestern habe ich übrigens die eine
hälfte meiner terrasse sauber gemacht
also die andere von relativ dreckig und
schaut euch das mal an wo es einfach so
aus und nachher sieht so aus ich bin
schon krasser gärtner also wenn ihr
wollt dass sich eure terrassen
saubermachen dann kontaktiert mich am
besten nicht denn ich habe aber noch
immer schmerzen jetzt die nachbarn die
hier in köln neben mir wollen sind aber
die größten ihre männer der welt die
machen gefühlte drei mal die woche sind
ja aber grundsätzlich immer zu viel und
geben die mir immer die reste und ich
hasse süßes wie tests allerdings kann
ich allen hinein sagen das ist so eine
nette gäst und das ist auch vorlieb und
meiner sotschi kommt auch immer weg also
wenn wir sind fast immer irgendwie
freunde abends da und jetzt das das ist
für den gartenbau die mensch und wir
besprechen
die kollektion von ersten sechster und
schaut euch das ja wie cool ist dieses
kissen bitte
ich sitze gerade im auto und ich freue
mich dazu freunden und mit denen falls
dann zum nürburgring der rennstrecke in
der nähe von köln und danach ein
bisschen spaß da habe ich weiter bin ich
jung
mir wurde gesagt die spenden kommen zwei
sachen
danke dir jetzt gute ware danke dir
[Musik]
alles klappt und jetzt am nürburgring
angekommen hier wurde die rennstrecke
sind egal ob im abgesperrten bereich und
ich hatte die idee dass ich gegen farbe
die ich muss ich erst mal vorstellen
dass du nicht zu sagen damit ihr party
mal ein bisschen besser kennen lernt
hier ein komplett unbearbeitet das
interview von ihm anfangs war ich
ziemlich nass wurde dann immer trockener
ich habe gehofft dass dies war sich so
für die poleposition reicht weil wir
dieses jahr schon mehrmals centerfold
war ich bin auch nicht so einfach ins
drucken ist legen wenn es regnet es
trocken ich fühle mich in allen
bedingungen wie heißt du fabian nachname
schiller der hasler der schiller der
zählappell bist du und ich bin 22 30 12
was machst du hauptberuflich leiterin
du fährst autorin heftig rennfahrer was
wir als private note ein ford raptor
hier mal ein foto wie viele formel 1
rennen hat es bereits gewonnen nicht
ganz fair ist kein formel 1 leider nicht
nehmen was soll denn ich war für
mercedes amg gehören also machen wir ja
stimmen rennens wird diese krass was ist
dann im ersten freien training am
nürburgring blue port 2070 passiert ist
ein bisschen feucht und dann hat ein
bisschen glück war wie viele unfälle das
insgesamt schon so 15 vielleicht 15 wie
fühlst du dich nicht von mir abgezogen
wird auf den 30 meter sprint das
unmöglich abgezogen die wette
jetzt stellt euch mal eben was gerade
passiert es uns war wollte mir hat ein
rennen veranstalten da sowie mit seinem
gt3 rs gegen mich zu fuß und ich hatte
mein handy hingestellt dabei ist es
allerdings umgefallen und verwies dann
hinter der mülltonne über das handy
drübergefahren achtet auf den zaun
sogar mein handy geortet mein handy war
beim filmen das heißt ich habe die szene
wie er darüber fällt quasi auf meinem
iphone die haben wir zunächst ein probe
rennen veranstaltet und die passende
entfernung herauszufinden
und ja als ich halt die mülltonne
berührt habe ist mein handy umgefallen
dann habe ich unserem kumpel philo
gesagt dass er mit der mülltonnen er zu
uns kommen soll da ich sonst absolut
keine chance habe
und dadurch dass die mülltonnen zehn
meter weiter vorne stand mein handy
allerdings umgefallen auf dem boden
liegen noch an der ursprünglichen stelle
lag ist folgendes passiert
[Musik]
hier noch mal eine andere kamera mexiko
und da liegt man heiles handy und jetzt
liegt darm ein kaputtes händen
ich dachte so super tag locken bisschen
mehr machen cooles rennen was passiert
iphone 11 schritte fühlt sich das so an
das handy von einer unschuldigen person
zerstört zu haben
ich wäre nichts für mich menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
die essen hier schon ihre welt die
palette der jetzt irgendwie fladenbrot
und ich hab ne pizza du bist mir tief
durch den heutigen doch jetzt allerdings
ob enten meine lieben freunde allerdings
wollte ich euch noch kurz sagen dass die
soeben gezeigten szenen im block also
beispielsweise das sich erst einmal mit
freunden oder dass wir am nürburgring
waren die ganzen sachen die er soeben
gesehen habe sind bereits eine woche her
das war letztes wochenende das wissen
auch alle dem über instagram folgen
allerdings will ich jetzt einfach nicht
dass das so rüberkommt als wenn wir
jetzt eigentlich gestern unterwegs waren
obwohl wir eigentlich alle zu hause
bleiben sollten ich nehme die
empfehlungen der regierungen der
expertin da wirklich sehr sehr ernstes
habt ihr auch in meinem gestrigen video
gesehen allerdings war der block
wirklich für heute für den donnerstag
einfach eingeplant also wirklich eine
woche ca danach wieder dem wir dieses
jahr aufgenommen haben ich will nicht
dass irgendwo rüberkommen wenn wir und
verantwortungslosen ich treffe jetzt mit
frauen und einkaufen das ist schon ein
bisschen her es tut mir leid wo ihm ist
übrigens auch eine neue podcast folge
dick und doof online gegangen link in
der infobox allerdings würde ich den
heutigen blog jedoch wieder mit einem
witz beenden
und zwar was ist kalt und fliegt nach
oben eine behinderte schneeflocke
[Musik]